PAREIDOLIA
you know what that means?
look it up son
pareidolia is a psychological phenomenon
in which the mind responds to a stimulus
usually an image or a sound
by perceiving a familiar pattern where none exist
basically you look at one thing
and you're like: wow that looks like this thing
that's what we're reviewing here today
that's what this channel is all about
so let's just jump into it guys!
let's go to number one...
"My favorite picture of Trump at his inauguration today"
OHHHHHHHHHH SNAHP
I especially like this one
'cus it's t r a s h
TRAAA AASH
it's kinda cute actually *chuckles*
it looks like some...
anime offspring cartoon version that just got cancelled
oh! oh it's the lid!
the lid is yellow!
ahh that's amazing!
well played
waeow
Patrick Stewart!
damn it I wish
I wish I didn't read the title first
if you don't know who Patrick Stewart is
here you go
let's get a side by side on this
Patrick Stewart reincarnated into a dog everybody
Pareidola huh
it's weird how it's turning me on a little bit
just me?
"show me what you got"
Oh damn, it's satan
oh, of course
I forgot we're on reddit
That's a--that's a Rick and Morty reference
"show me what you gottttttt"
bossfight
that looks like the final boss from like a Silent Hill game or something
alright I'm not gonna read the title
well that's a buffalo
Are you kidding me
If that's not a buffalo out in the fields
My mind is gonna be blown
What is it, one of those dentist lights?
That you pull down?
Oh hey there
It's a buffalo!
Okay.
Yeah it's at the dentist, yeah
Happy water buffalo at the dentist
Goddamn, that's awesome!
It looks like he's wearing headphones...
OH MY GOD! *chuckles*
Incredible.
It reminds me of that what has been seen,
cannot be unseen
But actually you know like the..
Double o seven golden eye.. cover?
You look at it your entire life
and you realize, that's- that's James Bond and then
you see this and you're like: "Goddamn it!
It's ruined forever!
Stohp it!
Stop that!
Well that's just WALL-E
Who murdered WALL-E
Who did it
Who did it guys
Disappointed
Maybe that's where they took the inspiration from
It's not unlikely
Okay not reading--okay